would you date a girl with an only fan
seriously and guys for us i'm gonna i'm
gonna answer first no i wouldn't why
wouldn't you why yeah
because um i don't want the father of my
like if i i would think of it as like a
long-term thing right i wouldn't want a
guy that i like am with publicly and
like father like that i'm a i feel like
it's like a brand like you know what i
mean because when you get married or
date someone that's they're like part of
your brand and i just feel like that's
not representing me
well because that's not something like i
would do or stand for so would you you
wouldn't you wouldn't
if you did own your fans but then when
you got serious he stopped that wouldn't
be okay
no you can't ever have done it
i just feel like if i could date someone
who had not done it like why would i not
there's so many men out there
like i think i could find one
guys follow my only fans
does it matter if the coin is really
good
you've changed your life
he can't change my life
yeah
that's arrangement
like respectfully um
no he can't like
no i i just think like because
like then what kind of person are you
you're like you change your values for
money
to an extent yeah yeah
that's honest out here man lisa's honest
right
i thought about this i've been through
certain things i'm just like
i know money isn't everything yet but
at this point in my life
i collect
i'll collect
yeah i know i mean i under i understand
like not everyone was raised and like i
had a really good situation growing up
so i understand but like
i just i feel like a long-term
relationship is kind of like a brand and
i feel like that's not what like i would
want my family
being known for is like the girl who's
dating someone with only fans
and even if it was like the best guy
ever like he he
he brought everything other than monday
night he was quite caring uh-huh he
looks for your needs he was actually
like for you but i wouldn't i wouldn't
want to get to that point
no but you never knew this she never
opened up because no one normally lied
oh no i'm in love you don't say it no
you're already pregnant with this child
well if you already knocked me off then
i'm of course like
it's your 20th 20th no no because it's
like
no i mean if i if i was pregnant i would
stay but that'd be very dishonest
tonight emily would you would you date a
guy who doesn't know any friends i'm
about to shock you all and uh and say i
couldn't give a [ __ ] um
yeah the shocking bit that was that was
sarcasm yeah uh
yeah i know i mean um i i have friends i
have friends who do only fans i view
them the exact same way as i did before
they had it uh i know so i don't know
any guys who do only fans i have a
friend who approached me because he
wanted to start and only fans with you
no no not with me although he did he did
ask if he could use my film expertise to
help him set it up
which i thought was jokes um
no it it man was trying it you know man
was trying um man doesn't need to try it
no he didn't end up doing it because he
worked like he works a corporate job
right he was just kind of going i kind
of want a little bit of money on the
side he's a bit of a hire like it fine
like but
it doesn't it doesn't bother me again
because i think
i can separate someone and their
career and i think if that's what you
want to do if that's how you earn your
money i think if you enjoy it you're not
being exploited in the sense of you know
you've not got a pimp there saying you
have to do this or i'm going to beat you
up if you if you know if this is how you
make your money i think ultimately if
you're someone who goes
i'm doing this at the moment because
and i actually hate it and i wish i was
doing something else i think that's sad
but i think there's a lot of people who
go actually i like the money and i'm
happy to do this because i'd rather do
this than sell myself for a corporate
job or sell my body breaking it stacking
shelves intestines
i agree with you like i don't care like
i don't care what people do like it's
not my business like what you do in your
personal time and i don't think that
says who you are as a person but i just
think like
you should be selective in who you date
but i guess for me that's not really
something that would determine whether
or not i'd be interested or selected in
other words right right yeah yeah don't
clarify with the only fans because
there's some people who just post like
naked pictures that just become a thirst
trap then it's obvious that just blow it
back up why don't you say where it would
matter to you
where would it matter to you
oh you no no only first period but i'll
just for you like you wouldn't mind your
your man like blowing backs out on your
fans i could yeah i literally couldn't
care less i couldn't care less if you
were having gay bear back with like an
orgy it really like it it doesn't bother
me but you were
jesus jesus has left the chat well like
what if you like yeah
did you be nervous about like if you had
kids and i'm like making fun of like
i mean who in in in your day-to-day life
so i follow a couple on instagram
they're called the london vagabond
they're a pink couple okay they
photograph kink
and people ask this question of of them
as well about whether or not um you know
what do their kids think of it what are
they
your normal parents don't talk about
your sex life
you're so it's it's some it's a similar
thing if you have a kink a particular
kink again of course you're not going to
it's an age appropriate thing i'm not
going to talk to my kids about the sex
that i have right generally speaking in
in a kind of yeah i mean you're done
yeah but i think like even even like
friends that i know that have had like
ho ho moms at some point they find out
like the kids grow up and they find out
right that's your role model though
and i guess maybe if you don't see
anything like wrong with that then like
we probably would just have different
like world views right because yeah i
would see something wrong with that you
probably wouldn't right but i also think
i think it's dependent on
i in general even if i've slept with a
lot of people even if someone has slept
with a lot of people that doesn't mean
that they're sleeping with people who
aren't good people they might just be
finding lots of good people in the same
way i think if you have a kid i think
that's a different game i think because
you are then way more selective because
you're bringing someone in
right is then coming into contact with
your kid especially i mean i think it's
different if you're going as a parent
i'm sleeping with them they're never
coming into contact with my kid but if
if your child has seen you bring people
back i think again that that child you
have to think about that child then
right who is around your child so i
think that's a different point right um
i guess when i date like i look more
like long-term you know what i mean so
that's like the way i think is like it
would be more of a long-term like
prospect you know what i mean yeah but i
think in general i don't sleep with
people that i don't respect right i
would never sleep with someone that i
didn't respect someone that i didn't
like and i think part of the problem of
people not being able to have long-term
relationships is that they don't date
people thinking can i be friends with
this person do i actually like this
person do i just want to i don't think
guys do that i think
i think more girls do that what and as
in i think even if a girl is looking at
a guy casually like she'll still care if
he's a decent person yeah whereas i
think yeah for sure a lot of guys can
separate that completely but well also
but i also think because mainly like
most guys don't have that level of
abundance
so they'll take what they can get
you think you don't you don't think most
guys have no i i agree i just feel like
you can
for example you can have a girl that
you're like that's your goal
and you can just
you can be with anybody like it doesn't
matter with
that's the point that i'm making like
yeah i agree with you oh okay yeah
like yeah but it don't matter it could
be that's well you can be she can be old
young
victims like any you don't matter like
it's just for that moment
yeah because i think when a guy sees a
girl that he finds attractive without
even knowing her name if she was like
yo i'm gonna come to this cup right now
nine times out of ten he's gonna say
he'd be like yeah but when a girl sees a
guy that's attractive even if she's like
oh he's really hot
a lot of the time and correct me if i'm
wrong ladies but i feel like a lot of
time you'd still be like even though i
would have sex i kind of still want to
know if you're a decent person before i
do it's more like i don't want to catch
anything
like i'm not trying to run a bad std and
you can't have kids so i'm not trying to
yeah i don't please please have please
please have protected sex yeah but you
can see there's still [ __ ] you can catch
with protected sex yeah for sure but but
me and i just feel like if a guy was
coming up to me and asking that i'm like
how many i can't be the first
i mean i mean let's let's put this into
context of real life
how many times have women come up to you
and gone do you want to come with me
into this back alley anyone has that
ever happened to any of you guys how's
it going
earlier but really openly you've never
had a conversation and they've
propositioned you straight off the bat
has that ever happened to any of you
guys not like the first thing she said
but within like a couple of minutes only
once yeah
the one i've got was
um they would say it but very s in a
certain way so i remember one time yeah
the girl was like oh do you want to come
back for cuddles
[Music]
yeah so yeah it'll be very soft it won't
be like guys what are that so are you
telling me
yeah yeah man i think guys the way guys
approach a guy in that manner is
different to how a woman approaches a
guy in a manner
if a girl approaches a guy in the same
way sometimes he can put you off but
you're like
that was a bit too easy like okay
there was nothing for me to work with
like it was just
take
i asked that because from a female
perspective my concern is more the
safety of the fact i don't know who you
are
and it's less about that's true it's
it's less about the fact you've
propositioned me openly for sex and more
about the fact you could hurt me
physically yeah yeah i don't i don't
know you
and also i think it's another thing of
intimacy right so much of sex for me is
intimacy i
couldn't sleep with someone i'd never
even had a conversation with who i knew
i didn't click with because how can i be
vulnerable with this person
first of all like the best sex i've ever
had has been with someone i've either
been in love with or i've been able at
least to be intimate with but you know i
already know them we already know we've
probably already had i'm a very open
person in case you can tell um so i'm
able to have a conversation with the
person i'm about to sleep with or i am
sleeping with about what i like what i
enjoy and if someone propositions you
straight off the bat yeah yeah okay
like the chances of it being good are
quite slim because they don't know who
you are they don't know what you like
they don't know what you enjoy you've
not had any conversation about consent
so i i think that's also i think that's
another thing guys what about you with
only fans would you date a girl with
only fans
not seriously no not seriously no no
no i wouldn't sound even though even
though you could understand getting on
it
any guy that would consider himself like
a proper man that would
wife
yeah that old wife
um
a girl that's unonly fans like that
see i feel like you have something to
see here give her the mic
give the girl the mic
she got some heat
that's strong words um
no just more this thing about uh what
what's what is a proper man what someone
who doesn't
uh yeah i guess to do with saying i'd
say a man with standards
and i think it's like important to like
have standards and we always tell men
that they can't have standards
i think it's important to have standards
but i think that's i don't think again
someone's numbers is a reflection of
their standards or what someone does for
a job but there's there's research that
shows that more of the more partners
like the woman has the less likely she
will be happy in the marriage
and the like the there's higher rates of
depression like there's a lot of things
that that are negative that are linked
to the more people you sleep with so
so so
so can like how is it
bad for a guy to say i don't want to
deal with that because that's just a
standard he has okay the thing i would
challenge with that how big are these
studies and also you cannot isolate
these all of these people have not had
the same life experiences so you cannot
isolate just the amount of people
they've slept with the the control
variables are slim but don't
i agree with you like that's that's
where their discernment comes in but
like i don't think there's anything
wrong with a guy saying like
like that he wouldn't date someone
that's not only fans oh i i mean yeah we
we've had this conversation as well i
said again i'm completely i can't make
you sleep with anybody i can't make you
go yeah absolutely what if you had a son
or a brother like you you really would
encourage them to like date someone with
an only fans it's not even a thing of
encouragement i'm neutral i would
encourage you to not be prejudiced i
would encourage you to view someone for
who they are as a person and i think
what you do for a job and who you slept
with it's completely irrelevant i think
it's about him so what if he's a
criminal the guy so if a guy if a guy's
a a criminal and he has a past of like
what's robbing yeah sex offenses like
you don't think your actions show who
you are oh and what kind of yeah but
again that's not to do with the fact
that he slept with women that's to do
with the way again like that's i think
that's a complete that's well that's so
left but i think but i think no but it
it does because a girl that's slept with
more
men like i think the the issue is
ensuring paternity they're worried that
when in the relationship she's going to
do the same thing because that's her
habits the last couple of years the same
way that like if a girl is looking at a
guy and he's cheated in every single
relationship he's been in like that
that's your habit that's what you do
that's who you are as a person okay but
i think sleeping with lots of people
doesn't equate you being a cheater i
think so when you say about a guy can't
guarantee paternity okay but if she's
someone who slept with a lot of people
but monogamously
then the trend is she slept with a lot
of people monogamously so it's like okay
she's only sleeping with you
monogamously we're talking about only
fans oh so so that's what we're talking
about like he said he like his he said
that he like a proper
like man wouldn't date a girl with an
online show
shall i tell you what i think it is
correct me from wrong right
is i think
the thing that i think sometimes girls
don't understand
about men
is that respect is very important
and respect amongst other men
especially men that you consider your
peers who you value men you look up to
men who look up to you is very important
and
if you're a guy and you have
committed and invested yourself
in
because things there are plenty of women
who may have great qualities as the girl
who hasn't only fans
but they don't have an only fans does
that make sense so i think if you as a
man have choose have chosen to commit
and invest yourself in
a woman that you feel doesn't
give great respect to you because your
partner is a reflection of you who you
choose is a reflection of you
then that does play a part in him
thinking okay is this somebody who i
want to represent me to the world does
that make sense so it i think you know
like chris you said you've got a name
right yeah right and you're nigerian
yeah so i'm nigerian so respect in our
culture is huge
massive and there are a lot of other
cultures like asian cultures like there
are a lot of other cultures where
respect is very important so
yeah i think um
i think that's when you say about being
a man part of being a man
is having the level of respect that you
desire which is you know a lot of guys
may look at will smith and be like
he doesn't have a lot of respect right
now
do you know what i mean and he hasn't
for a long time i think i think that's a
collective thing i think everybody wants
to be respected and i completely and
again another conversation that we've
had like societies that are much more
collective they're way less
individualistic
uk especially american society very
individualistic whereas if you're taking
countries asia africa there is a lot
more uh
importance on what society is a whole
and how you fit into society as a whole
yeah the community and i think that's a
really good thing in some senses but
those countries also have some of the
highest rates of suicide because they
have so much social shame
yeah but
i would say actually have the lowest
rates which is confused a lot of social
scientists yeah they have less look at
like japan it has one of the highest
rates because of social stigma and shame
if they do something wrong
when i went to japan like my my
understanding was it was more like
one um
it's a very individualistic society like
so yeah like people are dying alone in
their apartment there oh yeah and like
and and men are working themselves to
death so i don't i don't think it's like
social stigma but i don't i'm not saying
in terms of
people i'm not talking about people's
isolation because japan also has a
problem with not enough people having
children
yeah i know because it's back to like
the individualistic like like japan has
a problem with like women like that like
getting old and not being able to find
husbands basically right now but
historically and it's still the case
that they have very clear social rules
like even in terms of things if you
would never hold hands with your partner
or keep your partner on the street
because
society that's like that's frowned upon
socially really because i i went there
when i was younger and like that
the couple i stayed with like they were
i don't know that was not the case for
whatever
it's the same
it's like that in uae they're very
strict about like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
so and i'm saying more that the thing
with with
with with guys and this thing of okay i
want to be respected by my men and i
completely see that and i completely see
that and especially in other countries
where that is even more important or
different cultures where that's really
important and what being a man is
differently defined i think that's why
it's important to shift the societal
narrative of what we define as being a
good man as what we because i think it's
a lot of pressure to put on that i do
but i just think wrong i just think
things just like are
like i'm never gonna because when we're
saying we need to change society that's
just like you putting your world view
onto society and saying this is how you
should think
i don't do what i'm saying like like
because we have intern like like this is
what i mean when i say we feel shame
like that's that's a natural instinct
and there's a reason like everyone feels
the same like there's a reason men
respect the president of the united
states and look at that as a successful
man like there's a reason like women are
attracted to power ambition like some
stuff i don't think we can just
tell ourselves not to do it just like is
and i think for sure there's a certain
element of we you know you can't always
make someone think the same way as you i
can't magically force the uae to be
progressive overnight i can't make them
respect women i can't change like i as
an individual can't help these things
and i completely understand that for
some societies some cultures they don't
want that they don't want me to come in
and be like well i think but without
things like that we'd still have fgm
being acceptable
female genital mutilation which is
really widespread especially in africa
like and the more that we talk about
that and say actually that's really not
acceptable and i know a lot of people
make the argument the fallacy of
tradition we talk about in philosophy
the fallacy of tradition it's like just
because it's a traditional thing doesn't
mean it's a good thing or the right
thing or it benefits people so i think
there's it's i think i think it's a
give-and-take thing i think it's a thing
of no you shouldn't force your worldview
and you shouldn't force your opinion and
people are entitled to their opinion but
i think sometimes it's like these things
actually aid people so i would never
want a man to think you know he has to
act this way because without the respect
of someone else and he cares really what
this guy thinks then he's less of a man
and if he's less of a man then who is he
like i couldn't care do you think that's
just like even when you say like i don't
want to say less of a man because it's
like
i just feel like that's like dishonest
like there's hierarchies in every just
like every society of life and you can't
say like pretend they don't exist
doesn't make them not exist so for
example like a victoria's secret model
is hotter than me and if you're going to
like come up to me and say like oh
you're just as hot like
you could say that
like
but that's that's life and it's the same
thing with like guys there's hierarchies
with like men in terms of like and
because a lot of it's like they men
value like other men like they pick it
like they they pick who they respect and
who they don't
like yeah i mean yeah there's there's
hierarchy in everything whether that's
attractiveness or your kind of social
standing and you see it i was saying
before you see it so much in schools in
terms of popular kind of popularity
groups and i think it becomes more
redundant when you're in kind of
day-to-day society but i think the
problem with this this thing of what
what makes a good man or what what makes
a good woman it's not only are they kind
of two different things but i think that
they're abstract and i think in the same
way we go what is our net what is what
is a great british value well i think
it's supply and demand it's like supply
like when we go to talk about a good man
and a good woman it's supply and demand
it's like who do the most men want who
do the most women want
you know
i just think goodness is is tied much
more to
who you are as a person and less about
okay what do other people think of you
and actually do you treat people nicely
i think that's right like a good man is
the same thing as what a good woman is
right but usually like i don't know
i don't think
what a good man yes i think i think the
original point was just that he was i
think
when he was saying more of a man
i think is what we would
call a good example of what a man could
be and is
part of that or what contributes to that
is him having a respectable partner or
a perceived respectable partner because
i keep using this because it's fresh but
like will smith he's a good man
but i don't think he's been respected
for a long time
yeah he's not been respected as a man
for a long time especially within his
relationship but he's a very good man i
just i just don't think putting
limitations especially on the situation
of like
and this is this isn't an attack on you
at all of what you said it's more just
like the phrasing of it makes me go like
oh because i think um not me you can say
it
and not me
it doesn't i encourage you to be a man
no it doesn't make me think don't say it
it's more that i think um i think that
putting putting a limitation on your
partner in order to make you seem more
respectable is not necessarily healthy
well women do that to men though
that doesn't make it healthy
no i feel like it um the the quality of
the woman or like for example if she has
the only fans just for like for example
it does affect you as a man for example
look at will smith right before before
we knew all the stuff we knew about jada
right
we thought will smith was like
top dude he was the man we were yeah his
first prince on the show and then in
real life he was doing all these movies
and he was like will smith but now you
look at will smith and you just it's
hard to see him the same but even now if
you're watching the next movie it won't
it won't hit the same as
before the whole
just just the slap himself
and the way he's got mocked for that
that's one thing and then you've got
like for some kanye
i don't know how many people was the
kanye documentary
but like he's a he's very good at what
he does like he's top tier
um and you can see like he has good
intentions good with his family but
kim
like you can't look at kanye the same
because
the way his wife moves or hasn't moved
in the future because because it kind of
reflects the guy because it shows your
your discernment
that's it like because women like we
look for like men that have good
discernment because like when men are
more logical women are more emotional in
general so like when you pick a girl
that's a 304 like it shows a lack of
discernment and then for example you've
got katie price
yeah yeah like
she doesn't
stick with a guy and this goes back to
the the whole tendency thing and like
she had um
i could be wrong in it but it was i
think dwight was it dwight york her
first guy before
okay she had a football guy a foot
football player and then she's been in
other relationships with peter andre
yeah um even recently she was um
she had a fiance
and that's that ended you know
um
it's just like
your wife is a reflection of your wife
or your girl's reflection of you and
like
she can either increase your value or
lower your value just depending on how
that's perceived but i guess
so i guess i would i would i would
counter that with
these are also public figures and i feel
like that's a completely different
game to day-to-day life for people who
aren't famous i think life in the public
eye is a different thing entirely and
anyone who's in that public eye would
attest to that but i would also say that
i don't respect kanye not because he's
got with kim
because if you hear her speak for all of
the like and i'm and i'm the first one
to be like look okay these guys are
really not the epitome of role models
that we should necessarily hold up but
not because i'm like oh she made a sex
tape or whatever if you hear her speak
in interviews she's really intelligent
and she's starting like look at her
she's built a multi-million pound
business yeah but she also ruined the
family
she left the faint like
she like she broke a home
and like that's four kids who now like
have to grow up without a dad in the
house uh he like i don't i understand i
understand he's nuts but you picked him
like i'm sorry like he was crazy before
and like like
yeah like and that's what i'm saying
that's what happens when you like wife
of 304s they leave a lot of the time
like women leave 80 of the time in
divorce but this is the thing like i
would never have chosen kenya west in
the first place why would you have
chosen him but because he's like insane
like look at the way that he's in this
relationship now like okay and i'm
talking i'm trying to be a housewife
i know that okay i know that he has
mental health problems like and i think
that is a struggle in and of itself do
you respect him but no and i didn't
respect him before like i didn't respect
him before
because like any time i heard him speak
i just thought what is this guy talking
about okay so chatting on so so here's
the thing right
you wouldn't choose a guy you don't
respect the only difference in what
we're saying
is that
how
what contributes to a man's respect is
different to what contributes to a
woman's respect so like for example
like a woman is more respectful if she
like speaks very intelligently of course
and i don't disagree with you i think
she is a very intelligent person
but guys care more about how she acts
sexually
in terms of where the respect for her
comes whereas for women it might be okay
you may not care how he acts sexually
but you do care if he can articulate
himself you do care how intelligent he
is so i think
i think what we should say is like
respect respect is important to everyone
it's just got what guys use to
measure a woman's respect we just use
different metrics than what you guys use
i guess i just i guess it i mean i guess
i just
i feel
slightly maybe not baffled is the right
word i just think it's a bit of a shame
because i think that
like when we look at the case of will
and jada right i think
i think will's action will's action so i
was at a private like oscars viewing
thing
and i just wrapped on a project and i
was sat there with this director and
we're chatting away or whatever and i
see this happen on the screen and i
thought it was a stage punch
did you yeah and i saw him from the
audience and i was like oh
this guy is pissed this guy's probably
pissed no one shelves like that unless
they are [ __ ] red red with rage he's
an actor
no but but the but but he wasn't even
might like listen as well he's not even
miked and i just went oh that man's
pissed and then i was going oh my god
what just happened before i just chatted
through the whole like punch thing or
whatever
but i don't respect him because of the
like the what he did i don't think
that's uh i don't think that's good i
didn't you should assault comedians i
don't think that you should assault
anybody and i also think as well it's
like okay this person tells jokes for a
[ __ ] living like do you know what i
mean even if i didn't agree with the
person and i thought that's not a funny
joke i took that personally it's not
gonna make me fight someone but i think
that people have a lot of opinions on
the will and jada thing because they see
that they have a history of i i'm not
sure if it was cheating or pollyanna
it's because it's because of what gina
chose to put on red table talk yeah but
choice again this thing of like
celebrity i find it so strange i'm like
but it's the same thing if you if you
like it might happen on a like the
reason we look at celebrities is because
they represent like our normal life
so like like for example i know a lot of
guys that have trouble in like custody
like getting custody of the kids and so
when kanye was going through that it
kind of represents like part of like a
problem in society because if a
billionaire can't get custody of his
kids like what what does that say about
society right same thing like if if you
wife a 304 that like talks
right on online it might not happen at
like a global scale but like you can
still embarrass your dude in your
community
you know what i'm saying like it might
it might not happen at that big of a
level but these people like they
represent what's happening in society
just at like a global scale does that
make sense yeah i suppose i just i
actually
respect them for the fact that um
i mean she wouldn't speak on it on a
podcast
unless he was happy for her to do so i
think we could all agree that they have
a stable enough relationship you think
you think she listens
oh my god no she she just said that she
didn't agree with the slap no no no no
i'm saying is in i
when they talk about when she talks
about like the the kind of sexual
relationship that they have and like
their open relationship and things
wouldn't you spoken on that right they
had they had talks they had august on
red table talk
who's august
the guy the guy that she essentially
cheated with like 20 years younger but
interesting i'll be honest i think jd is
going to do whatever she wants to do but
yeah i think my point is like i i
in a sense respect the fact that
these people
regardless of what people think of jada
because i think she
gets a lot of flack i don't know all of
the insider goss by the way i'm up at
the other yeah but
i think that i respect them for the fact
that will is a is is clearly standing up
and saying actually you know we have
this kind of relationship or you know
we've we've had a bit of an open
relationship and i still love my wife
and things and i think okay fair enough
regardless of what i think of the
dynamic of your relationship i
appreciate the fact that that this
person is going now i still stand with
my wife i think that's
i think that's that's i think that is a
good thing but i think
like going back to the original point i
think that
uh i think it's just a i think it's just
a bit of a shame that like that that we
view how like the the way that we
view our respect of men versus women
that it's that it's not a similar thing
in the in our respect of men is is
deemed on you know
respectable things like you know are you
intelligent
you know are you ambitious these good
qualities and women are reduced down to
have you slept with lots of men well
it's not reduced down to it's like
that's easier
you know much harder it is to be a dude
you just have to not get fat okay as a
girl not get fat not sleep with too many
people and you'll you'll find a husband
but like men if they want to get a woman
they have to make a lot of money they
have to go to the gym
they have to like there's a long list of
[ __ ] that like women look for
i think guys do too and i think it's i
think as we move away that's not true
that's not true no because statistically
like like if you if you survey women
like i could point out study after study
after study showing you that's not true
because if you look at dating app swipes
men swipe right like 50 of the time and
on top of that like they surveyed men if
you go on a first date with a girl she
has 80 of the things you look for would
you go on a second date men said yes
women said no like women are pickier
it's much harder for a man to like get
girls than it is for girls to get guys
even even as even in commitment terms
yeah i think in terms of on the surface
level of what what do people want and
again going back to that thing of
abundance yeah but i think
every guy i know every single res like
guy who i go oh we're friends we're
these are these are guys who i really
respect
none of them like of course they could
go okay yeah i would maybe swipe right
on her but none of them would stay if
she had no personality no ambition no
hobbies no interest
sure a guy a guy with options you're
correct like the guys that can will but
like my point is
like we're complaining about this double
standard right but it's like it's not
even that bad to be honest it might like
i think it's much harder for men on the
other end because they have to like
build up to be something that women want
unless you're just born really
good-looking and tall
i think
some men are lucky
when you came to my channel you said
when you're dating apps like
you look at most of the girls you go oh
yeah like with most girls you can see
something attractive that you go yeah i
just go on a date with you you look at
the guys and you're like most guys
you're like what the [ __ ] is this you
even said that so it's like
and
so here's the question do you think you
apply a different standard to men than
you do to women when you're dating them
no i think it's a thing of am i
do they have a good personality are they
physically attractive i i look for the
same things the same traits
but i think my my point when we were
speaking before is i think there are
objectively more pretty women in the
world than there are good-looking man so
do you like a guy who's taller than you
and we also spoke about this and i again
i've dated people who were short like
someone who was actually shorter than me
and i've dated people who were all
[ __ ] than me what like would you
prefer a guy who's taller
oh fine don't cap like what i mean is
imagine you've got the guy he's got
amazing personalities right
there's one version of him where he's
six foot one and there's one version of
him when he's five foot four
who are you gonna choose
that's actually that's a really
interesting question are you saying it
has no berry i actually don't know no i
actually don't know do you care for
girls taller than you
i actually prefer girls who are taller
than me yeah you do i actually prefer
taller girls yeah have you dated me
you're in luck
yeah i tend to prefer girls who are
taller than me maybe i would with guys
say that maybe if there was a side by
side i don't think and i don't think
it's a bad thing because you know i've
got quite a few friends who are bi as
well and it's like
they they probably they apply a
different standard to men than they do
for women
and i think ugly i would agree i do i i
would say there's more attractive girls
than guys yeah
um
but there is a burden there is a higher
burden of performance on men
in terms of
to in terms of being attractive in
general in comparison to women find 80
of men unattractive
yeah i can i can relate to that yeah do
you find 80 of women unattractive
no but then i feel like my attraction to
women
how do is put this but do you see what
i'm saying what i'm saying like it's
much harder for men in dating
like in just like oh like yeah
for sure in terms of like and again
talking about like abundance and things
like that i think
because if there are all of these pretty
women and i think they'd go oh my god
he's the he's the top guy
i think for sure but i think again a lot
of that is reducing it down to dating
out but then so then could you
understand like when men like really
don't have a ton of standards that it's
okay like like that they might say like
that that's a standard for them is that
either a low body count or no only fans
yeah and again like i completely i'm
like if that's if that for you is a deal
breaker i respect that that's fine
you're allowed to have that opinion
but for me it's just more about
but why do you have that opinion one and
one in three men are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the last year i think
that's under
days
isn't it
in three men are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the past year
that's brutal yeah that's brutal
i'm gonna read some super